Hello, the Internet, I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
We're The Slow Mo Guys.
And back in the day, Daniel,
before we had our channel,
one of my favorite shows on YouTube was
"Is It A Good Idea to Microwave This?"
Almost never was a good idea.
Rarely. One of my favorite videos they did
was they put an airbag in a microwave.
Yeah.
And as you can imagine,
ain't no microwave no more
after that.
Thing with that video, though
you couldn't really see
exactly what happened
because they just sort of put it in,
ran out the door, and it exploded.
So we have no idea what happened.
So, let's reveal what actually happened
by using state of the art slow motion cap-
We all know what's gonna happen.
Yeah.
The airbag's gonna blow the door off.
It's gonna blow the bloody door right off.
Innit?
Gonna blow the bloody
door right off, innit.
Yeah.
Great.
Let's go.
Loving the old retro knob microwave
Thanks, yeah.
These are actually quite
hard to get hold of.
There's a reason that
we've got this, though.
And that's because,
all you have to do with one of these ones
is put what you're putting
in into the microwave
and close it.
If you set the dial to
"On," and plug it in,
it'll automatically just turn on and go.
So you can be miles away, just plug it in,
and it's gone.
With one of the digital
ones, it's not the same.
You have to be there and pushing buttons
and I don't want to be
anywhere near this thing.
The only airbags we could get ahold of
had these pins in, uh,
which is no good for us,
because we need these cables
to be attached to them,
so I've got these jumper cables,
which will hopefully make it work.
Because without that,
it doesn't do anything.
It just cooks.
Yeah. It just melts a little bit.
It just gets a bit melty.
So you need the cables in there
to get it to work.
Little antenna. All right.
Gonna film this in the Phantom Flex 4KF.
I actually set it to HD,
giving us a maximum frame
rate of 2,000 frames a second
and a very long trigger cable,
so I can trigger the camera
from safety over there.
Safety with Daniel.
Aw.
You ready?
Yeah.
Whoa. Well that took off.
That went flying.
Goodness me.
Bloody hell.
You unplugged it?
Yeah, it's unplugged.
That's got some distance on it,
look at that.
It must've hit the fence as well.
It did...it did hit the fence.
Careful, be hot.
Still hot, yeah.
Oh, that airbag pong
Ah, a familiar smell on the Slo Mo Guys
Oh, properly bowed it.
Look at that.
Oh! Bloody came clean off.
Oh!
You know I'm surprised none
of it went over the fence
it went upwards.
Yeah, it came off with some force.
That is wicked.
Microwave's not light
and it's just lifted it
off the table.
Can you imagine doing that in the kitchen?
Pff, annihilate the kitchen.
Yeah.
I like the billowing
smoke as it goes down.
It definitely adds to the effect.
Because it ejected the door so far,
sort of want to get a wide of it.
Okay.
Maybe just focusing on the, uh, door,
if it happens that way again.
Can we make it fancy, and maybe put some
powder paint in there? Colors and stuff?
We're really into powder paint these days.
That's why our channel has become like
can we put powder paint on that?
Well it's like, it makes
it look nice, you know?
Let's do it, let's burn some powder paint.
All right, we got black microwave now.
Gonna color it up though,
some primary colors.
Chuck a bunch of green on, first of all
Not a primary color, but alright.
Well, alright, yeah good point.
What I meant was like uh,
yeah just screwed myself over there.
Obviously it's not a primary color.
Made with blue and yellow.
Yup!
So, don't know why I said that.
But, chuck in blue.
What are the chances this
will just come out as a
like a brown of sort?
Oh, it's definitely going to, yeah.
Alright, that'll do, that'll do.
Okay then, I'm setting the
timer on the microwave.
Is it nerve wrecking doing
that in front of the door?
Yeah, even though I know
it's not plugged in,
it's impossible.
Hope this bag is good in.
Okay, we ready?
Yeah.
Oh! Surprises me every
time, gets me every time.
I'm weak!
What's weak?
I wanna say it.
So it looks like, it's
like identical pans,
it's completely symmetrical
except not quite as far.
I wonder if it's the powder
paint that had that effect.
Now uh, I've seen the
footage and you haven't.
Yeah.
Not quite as far would be incorrect.
Really?
Yeah.
How is that.. well look,
it's not gone as far
as the other one.
Unless, you're telling me
it bounced off the fence,
and then came back.
It annihilated the fence.
Oh!
So if anything it was stronger
because it bounced further
back off the fence.
Flip!
Do you want to see the footage?
Yeah, I mean how much do you
think you'd have to pay me
to stand here?
Oh, yeah, you'd break a bone.
Oh!
You'd absolutely get,
I mean if it hit you in the face,
it could do some serious damage.
All right, here we go.
Chilling.
Whoa, look at the force.
Whoa! It's like a jet trail isn't it?
The paint leaves like a powder trail.
Whoa!
That's going some speed.
Look at the way it's digging the fence,
it like properly bounced the fence panel.
Oh whoa, there's like a
gap in the fence after.
That's some serious ..
It might have broken the fence.
Look at it!
If you stood there, you'd be dead.
Is that a car crash?
Sounds like it, yeah, it was.
Well this one jumped back
about two meters there.
It's almost like the
explosion caused the microwave
to go that way and the
doors to go that way
in equal amounts of force.
Yeah, it just turned
into brown muck in there.
There's lot of paint in there.
But it's completely mixed and just,
Yeah it looks like the green on the front
is what that came out.
Yeah.
Pretty cool though.
I like the little trail it left behind.
Well it looks like we found
a pretty consistent way
to weaponize a microwave door.
You couldn't get me to
stand in front of that
there's no way.
You definitely wouldn't wanna do that.
No.
Don't try that one yourselves.
That's a real dangerous one.
Yeah.
Obviously, we did it because
we saw it in a video.
Ah, professionals and
everything though, so.
We're all professionals so.
Yeah, yeah.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video
feel free to follow us on Twitter,
go and watch the old
microwave show, it's top.
And, we've got a second channel,
which you should subscribe
to if you would like
a bit of a BTS.
And obviously, subscribe on this one.
Don't smash the 'like' button, though.
It's extremely delicate.
Fragile.
Be very gentle with the 'like' button.
A lot of YouTube is telling everyone
to smash the 'like' button.
Just caress it gently.
That's vandalism.
Yeah.
Done! Let's go.